on va installer le studio
[Musique]
là je vais être trop bien pour l'instant
je suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon câble
en fait
j'ai filmé mon frère pendant 20 ans d'un
petit appart en bordel au plus grandes
salles de France
mais pour lui c'était pas la partie la
plus compliquée
dans la musique c'est facile de percer
mais c'est plus dur de rester
j'en suis un peu pro au stade où je me
dis mais pourquoi je refais un album en
fait
mon frère c'est Orelsan et quand il
s'est lancé dans un nouvel album j'ai
continué de filmer partout
[Applaudissements]
tu es contente j'avais une question en
tête comment il allait revenir après son
plus grand succès pour ceux qui a un
enjeu de ouf sur l'album je voulais tout
filmer du premier mot écrit à la
dernière note jouée on est dans les
studios de Pharrell Williams
pour elle il est toujours tout seul au
début
il faut le laisser mais pas trop
écoute folie et ses éclairs de génie
j'ai plein de spi tous les trucs
auxquels je pense sont bien je descends
aussi bas que je suis monté au [ __ ] de
merde je trouve tout nul
je me suis trompé de branches je chante
faux et je sais pas faire des musiques
c'est rare quoi des chansons qui sont si
bien écrites
de l'album on va pas y arriver c'était
la guerre dans ce petit objet se cache
la dernière aventure de mon frère ses
potes et moi
et après j'arrête le rap